Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Please meet NeuroSAT.
The name of this technique tells us what it
is about, the neuro part means that it is
a neural network-based learning method, and
the SAT part means that it is able to solve
satisfiability problems.
This is a family of problems where we are
given a logic formula, and we have to decide
whether these variables can be chosen in a
way such that this expression comes out true.
That, of course, sounds quite nebulous, so
let’s have a look at a simple example - this
formula says that F is true if A is true and
at the same time not B is true.
So if we choose A to be true and B as false,
this expression is also true, or in other
words, this problem is satisfied.
Getting a good solution for SAT is already
great for solving many problems involving
logic, however, the more interesting part
is that it can help us solve an enormous set
of other problems, for instance, ones that
involve graphs describing people in social
networks, and many others that you see here.
This can be done by performing something that
mathematicians like to call polynomial-time
reduction or Karp-reduction, which means that
many other problems that seem completely different
can be converted into a SAT problem.
In short, if you can solve SAT well, you can
solve all of these problems well.
This is one of the amazing revelations I learned
about during my mathematical curriculum.
The only problem is that when trying to solve
big and complex SAT problems, we can often
not do much better than random guessing, which,
for some of most nasty ones, takes so long
that it practically is never going to finish.
And get this, interestingly, this work presents
us with a neural network that is able to solve
problems of this form, but not like this tiny-tiny
baby problem, but much bigger ones.
And, this really shouldn’t be possible.
Here’s why.
To train a neural network, we require training
data.
The input is a problem definition and the
output is whether this problem is satisfiable.
And we can stop right here, because here lies
our problem.
This doesn’t really make any sense, because
we just said that it is difficult to solve
big SAT problems.
And here comes the catch!
This neural network learns from SAT problems
that are small enough to be solved by traditional
handcrafted methods.
We can create arbitrarily many training examples
with these solvers, albeit these are all small
ones.
And that’s not it, there are three key factors
here that make this technique really work.
One, it learns from only single-bit supervision.
This means that the output that we talked
about is only yes or no.
It isn’t shown the solution itself.
That’s all the algorithm learns from.
Two, when we request a solution from the neural
network, it not only tells us the same binary
yes-no answer that was used to teach it, but
it can go beyond that, and when the problem
is satisfiable, it will almost always provide
us with the exact solution.
It is not only able to tell us whether the
problem can be solved, but it almost always
provides a possible solution as well.
That is indeed remarkable.
This image may be familiar from the thumbnail,
and here you can see how the neural network’s
inner representation of how these variables
change over time as it sees a satisfiable
and unsatisfiable problem and how it comes
to its own conclusions.
And three, when we ask the neural network
for a solution, it is able to defeat problems
that are larger and more difficult than the
ones it has trained on.
So this means that we train it on simple problems
that we can solve ourselves, and using these
as training data, it will be able to solve
much harder problems that we can’t solve
ourselves.
This is crucial, because otherwise, this neural
network would only be as good as the handcrafted
algorithm used to train it.
Which in other words, is not useful at all.
Isn’t this amazing?
I will note that there are handcrafted algorithms
that are able to match, and often outperform
NeuroSAT, however, those took decades of research
work to invent, whereas this is a learning-based
technique that just looks at as little information
as the problem definition and whether it is
satisfiable, and it is able to come up with
a damn good algorithm by itself.
What a time to be alive.
This video has been kindly supported by my
friends at ARM Research, make sure to check
them out through the link in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!